uh my name is changsha and this talk is
going to be
about an open source project called
rikai
that's designed to simplify data
management and analytical workloads on
images and videos
and i don't know if robert e is in the
audience but if he is he was asking me
who i was on twitter
uh like 15 minutes ago so
this is me
um so uh you know that's me uh
i was uh the second uh contributor to
pandas in a past life uh also vp of
engineering at 2btv most recently
and i just started a new company called
eto.ai
and my co-creator for the project who is
here in spirit his name is lay uh most
recently he was machine learning
platform lead at cruz
um
and
basically you know the reason why we
started this project was in our
experience when
we saw our ml teams working on projects
with unstructured data sets images and
videos that always took
three times as long as projects that
only had to deal with tabular data
ml engineers were always having to
kind of spend a lot of time and effort
like organizing the data managing those
images of videos they were writing for
loops that
directly manipulated very low level like
object storage
um
and they were wasting a lot of time
trying to to join the data they
extracted
um
with metadata or with related structured
data sets from from other places right
um so one example from 2b was like you
know if you needed to extract you needed
to extract
features from
poster images or you know from the video
content and then you obviously had to
join that with let's say like user
engagement data and things like that to
for personalization ads understanding
and and all sorts of good stuff
so you know rikai is kind of our
attempt to solve this problem and our
kind of our conclusion was that
what machine learning on structured
datasets was missing was a data
management layer where i was missing a
layer to to manage that successfully in
query it in the same way that you're
used to let's see sql engines or data
frame
tooling in tabular land right
so um
what is what is rikai so rikai is a
framework that is designed to solve this
problem for
ml workflows on uh unstructured data
sets uh you can find it at github.com
eto dash ai reci and it comes with three
main components there's a there's a
lightweight data format uh that
consists of semantic types on top of
parquet
and then there's a sql ml extension uh
we've implemented on top of spark for
now
and then i o connectors that help
connect the data format to
uh you know pytorch tensorflow and all
the framework frameworks that you need
to go about your machine learning
workflow
uh so quickly let's go through some of
the
the the main components so on the data
format
um
you know the semantic types are defined
in python uh the here you have an image
um
what's the
sorry i don't know how you oh yeah here
you have an image uh type here and then
um we have readers for pandas torch and
tensorflow
and then you have um the crd currently
is done through spark
at least for now
and the advantage of you know us bolting
this onto parquet is that it's you know
already scannable from
these existing big data tools so you
don't you're not really wholesale
replacing a lot of stuff
you so even if you're not
if you're using a tool that doesn't
understand rikai
as long as i can understand parquet you
can at least read that information out
so
so the semantic types in rikai are a
very rich set of ml domain specific
types images videos
annotations
like bounding boxes and labels so on and
so forth and then each one of them have
useful helper methods
and then arikai knows when and how to
convert parquet data to like tensors or
numpy numpy arrays or pill data formats
so you're not you don't have to worry
about kind of converting data back and
forth between different steps in your
workflow
um let's skip this one
so uh on top of the data format we also
have a
sql extension and
uh here you can run arbitrary models
from
pytorch or tensorflow or sklearn or you
can easily add additional model flavors
from like onyx format or you know
something else or just any arbitrary
code
and you can invoke it as a spark udf in
your spark sql as ml predict with just
the model name
and then we're also building out a model
evaluator with model eval and the
implementation here is just we're
jitting a
pandas udf right as the model executor
the model itself
is regis is registered with a model
registry and currently we support like
ml flow or you can just directly have
yaml configurations on an s3 file
so i'm really happy that uh peter's not
here but i'm really happy he went before
me and explained this idea of like
finding bad labels through model
disagreement model agreement uh because
this is exactly what this create
query gives you
it's an easy way to
to kind of find mislabeled data
automatically in your data set right so
here what i'm doing is right i'm running
the yellow v5 object detection model and
also another one ssd on this image and
then what i'm doing is looking at where
the models agree with each other more
than the models agree with the ground
truth which is the human labeling right
so
and the logic is
if the models agree with each other more
than they agree with human labeler
then it might be a bad label and we can
flag it for the for the user so here
i didn't have to
to
figure out okay like loop through the
images on s3
i didn't have to figure out okay how do
i like how do i convert that image file
and that's on s3 into the tensor that i
can feed into my model what is my model
interface
while all that's done
for you and it's just a simple sql query
and so you can extend this easily to all
of the other uh kind of
um
scenarios that you know
and peter mentioned and also
uh other kind of ml workflows and data
mining and data exploration situations
um
so uh to continue so rikai also has i o
connector so it's very easy
for us to read and write rekhai data and
like spark and
torch data sets and tensorflow data sets
we also have data converters from
popular kind of machine learning formats
so uh
rikai understands how to convert like
coco format data ros bags and then we're
building out new scenes and and kitty
conversion
and more
um
the last thing i'll mention here is that
rikai also has visualization tooling and
so when
users are working with data scientists
are working with
images and videos and like say jupyter
notebook
it's
they often need to look at
the images with the annotations and
labels kind of label put put on there um
and if they don't want to kind of go to
a different tool to do that but in
jupyter notebook the tooling is very low
level right so you often have to go to
like opencv or like pillow uh apis
directly instead well because we can
recall understands the the types of
these things uh we can introduce higher
level api so rik has you know
displayable abstraction which are things
that can be shown to the user a drawable
abstraction which is like stuff that you
can draw onto these displayable objects
and then renderer is where we've
implemented a pill renderer that can be
shown directly in the notebook itself
all right so just a quick example here
um so on the left
you'll see like here's you know in in um
a note jupiter notebook today if you
were to draw
a image with like bounding boxes on it
this is kind of the code that you have
to write in opencv uh with rikai it's
just this so you i don't have to worry
about okay i need to draw a rectangle
and i need to figure out the position
and then like i need to know exactly
which fields coming out coming or coming
out of the the the images and and the
bounty boxes i just put them all
together and then boom i'm done
um
so
uh i forgot who who tweeted this before
but uh
like every new data project has to
has to have a slide that looks like this
have a before and after slide so who are
we to rock the boat
and essentially this is kind of
about
you know the main value of of what recy
provides it's the same data management
abstraction that gives us a single
source of truth that's consistent
throughout our ml workflow
so whether you're doing search or
training analysis or bi
you don't actually have to do all any of
the manual data conversion yourself you
can just use the i o connectors enrique
and plug it into the tooling that you're
already familiar with and then with the
sql extensions we're also bringing
standard data tooling to these ml and
all data sets
for querying
all right um
okay five minutes so plenty of time uh
so
so uh we built out uh
rikai um
over the past year or so uh we're
looking at a roadmap where
we've started out supporting uh text or
image and video data and we're looking
to expand that into like text data and
sensor data and geo geospatial data and
then
currently we rely on spark for kind of
crd but we want to make native writers
that make the this whole thing kind of
spark independent
um
for sql extensions we need to
be able to access udt's a little bit
better and then we're thinking about
kind of porting the same extensions and
let's say like presto or or dask
and then lots of additional model
support and visualization nice uh nice
features
um and then yeah so this is uh this is a
little bit about rikai and i wanted to
kind of
uh end on a as a thank you to both you
guys for listening to me rant and then
also thank you to kind of the
contributors of the rikai project so far
we'd love for you to kind of check us
out on github
try us out and give us some feedback
okay
[Applause]